The new Mortal Kombat film is filled with easter
eggs, both in what is shown, and what characters
say. Here are the lines in Mortal Kombat that
have a deeper meaning than first meets the eye.
One of the central narrative arcs in
Mortal Kombat is the rivalry between
Hanzo Hasashi who becomes Scorpion
and Bi-Han also known as Sub-Zero.
The film opens with Bi-Han killing
Hanzo's entire clan, family, and
then the man himself. Before he does, Bi-Han says:
"...the Shirai Ryu, have been exterminated by me."
With this line, the movie fast-tracks the
backstory of Scorpion and Sub-Zero's clans
and their long-simmering blood-feud. The Shirai
Ryu clan itself is actually an offshoot from
Sub-Zero's, called the Lin Kuei, which began
when a member defected and started amassing
their own followers. The Lin Kuei did not
take this defection lightly and made it their
mission to wipe the new Shirai Ryu clan out of
existence. Hence, Sub-Zero's bloody mission.
Cole Young, the once successful MMA
fighter who now can't win a match,
is first approached about the Mortal Kombat
tournament by Major Jax Briggs after an
unsuccessful fight. Even though we just saw Cole
take a pretty decisive loss, Jax refers to him as:
"The man that took the belt from Eddie Tobias."
The line is delivered in a manner that is clearly
meant to make it seem like Eddie Tobias
is a formidable MMA fighter. The fact that
Cole once robbed him of a title means he was
much more successful in his younger years.
But that's beside the point. The name itself is
also meant to be a loving reference to Ed Boon
and John Tobias, the developers credited
with creating the first Mortal Kombat game.
Another deep concept that gets a cursory mention
in the movie is that of the Elder Gods. When Shang
Tsung is preparing to assassinate the Earthrealm
warriors, Mileena pushes back by asking:
"What of Lord Raiden? If he discovers we're
breaking rules set in stone by the Elder Gods..."
The Elder Gods are beings whose job is to
ensure balance among the many realms by using
non-interventionist methods. Despite Mileena's
fear of them retaliating against Shang Tsung for
breaking the rules they've set, the Elder
Gods themselves are not all-powerful.
Similar to the pantheon of Greek deities, the
Elder Gods are significantly more human in the
way they operate than other interpretations
of a divine and omniscient being. The Elder
Gods Shinnok and Cetrion have even been
playable characters in the game series.
Considering the Amulet of Shinnok appeared
as an Easter egg moment in the movie,
we’re curious to see how much of a role the
Elder Gods play in the film series going forward.
When the Earthrealm warriors find Raiden's
temple, Cole and Kano are quickly put on
an intense training regime in order to build
their skills and unlock their arcana abilities.
As Kung Lao begins to put the would-be defenders
of the realm through their paces, he says:
"All you can do now is test your might."
That line is pretty straightforward in the context
of the movie, but it's also a sly reference
to the first Mortal Kombat. Between fights,
players would occasionally be tasked with
competing in a button-mashing minigame called
"Test Your Might," wherein their character had
to punch through blocks of wood and other strong
materials to score points. The nonchalant callback
in the 2021 movie seems like an Easter egg left
specifically for players whose love of the
games goes all the way back to the first.
Although Liu Kang has been featured as the
protagonist for many of the games and movies
in the Mortal Kombat universe, he plays
more of a supporting role in the 2021 film.
He still gets the opportunity to shine some
light on his backstory, though. While speaking
with Cole between training sessions, he reveals:
"Unlike Kung Lao, I was just a worthless stray.
For reasons beyond my ken, master Bo'
Rai Cho found me half-dead in a gutter
and brought me to the Wu Shi Academy."
Like many of the franchise's characters,
Liu Kang's backstory got fleshed out
considerably as the series went on.
"I die in the Koliseum? You on a rooftop, fighting
Lord Raiden? Our future, Liu Kang. It is insane."
The 2002 game Mortal Kombat: Deadly Alliance
introduced the character Bo' Rai Cho,
the Outworld martial arts grandmaster who turned
his back on his home-realm to train Earthrealm
warriors like Liu Kang and Kung Lao. Bo' Rai
Cho's status as an Outworlder on the side of
Earthrealm makes him a significant character
in the general lore of the games, especially
considering Liu Kang secured several Earthrealm
victories in the Mortal Kombat tournaments.
While many characters in the Mortal Kombat series
have fascinating histories and storylines, there
are only a handful that have real significance
to the broader arc of the story. The 2021 film
smartly brings in several that are less important
as fatality fodder, one of those being Kabal.
In the movie, Kabal is introduced as an assassin
working for Shang Tsung and an associate of
Kano's. He even says of his old frenemy:
"He's the reason I live in an iron lung."
Kabal's distinct mask and breathing apparatus
have been a hallmark of his character since
he was first introduced in Mortal Kombat 3.
However, while the movie implies that Kano
caused the injuries that put Kabal in his iron
lung, in the games, the story is a bit different.
In 2009's Mortal Kombat, a reboot that retells the
story of the first three games, Kabal is a police
officer who sustains grievous injuries during
Outworld's invasion of Earthrealm. He's found
by Kano, who fits him with his respirator that
allows him to breathe despite the damage to his
lungs. So, in the games, Kano quite literally puts
Kabal in his iron lung, but only to save his life.
Although Raiden's warriors feel outmatched
by Shang Tsung's collection of assassins,
the former ends up pretty much wiping
the floor with the latter. That doesn't
seem to bother Shang Tsung too much, though.
Shortly before the credits roll, he announces:
"Today you have killed my warriors and you think
you have won. But death is only another portal."
The Mortal Kombat games have featured
several narrative arcs wherein previously
slain characters rise from the dead. In Mortal
Kombat 3, Shang Tsung helps resurrect Sindel,
the wife of Outworld Emperor Shao Kahn. Similarly,
the tenth installment of the series saw multiple
dead characters return as mind-controlled versions
of their former selves known as Revenants.
The evil sorcerer also menaces the
Earthrealm warriors with a warning:
"Next time I see you I will not
bring fighters, I will bring armies."
While the first two games tell stories that
are relatively contained to the tournaments,
Mortal Kombat 3 features an all-out war. The plot
of the game sees Shao Khan enlisting Shang Tsung
to pull some trickery that ends with
the emperor invading Earthrealm with
armies of Outworld warriors.
If or when the Outworld invasion
happens in the films, Shang Tsung's threat
to come back with armies is not an idle one.
The original Mortal Kombat had a
relatively small roster of characters.
There were only seven playable fighters and
three special bosses included in the game.
All ten of those characters made an
appearance in the 2021 film except for one:
The vain martial artist
and movie star Johnny Cage.
Cage doesn't make a physical appearance in
the first movie, but based on the ending,
fans will be seeing him if there's a sequel.
After defeating Shang Tsung's forces, we see
Cole in the locker room of the MMA arena when
he's approached by his fight booker. He declines
the man's offer to appear in a matchup, saying
that he's off to Hollywood. The man replies:
"Hollywood? What the hell's in Hollywood?"
Fans of the series likely knew the answer
to that question as soon as it was asked.
But to hammer home reference, the camera
lingers on a poster for a movie starring
Johnny Cage right before the credits roll.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Mortal Kombat
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.